[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue non pas sur le plateau
d' interdit d'interdire mais chez moi
confinement oblige nous allons consacrer
deux émissions à la seconde guerre
mondiale ont quand même en effet le 8
mai prochain l'anniversaire de la
défaite de l'allemagne nazie et ses deux
émissions nous allons les faire avec
jean lopez le directeur de la du
magazine guéret l'histoire grands
historiens notamment qui a écrit
beaucoup de livres sur le front de l'est
mais à qui l'on doit également avec
olivier wieviorka les mythes de la
seconde guerre mondiale paru chez perrin
bonjour jean lopez commençons si vous le
voulez bien par le front de l'ouest
toute cette première émission on va là
consacré au front de l'ouest on verra le
front de l'est dans la dans la seconde
et commençons par la défaite de la
france il y a maintenant 80 ans
aujourd'hui on peut l'expliquer cette
défaite oui oui bien sûr il y aura
toujours des désaccords à droite à
gauche mais on sait aujourd'hui
grosso modo l'essentiel de la
l'essentiel de la catastrophe s'explique
par des insuffisances militaire et non
pas comme on a voulu le croire à
certaines époques en la cuisant soit les
soldats
1 la fameuse phrase assassine neuf mois
de belote 6 6 semaines de course à pied
à l'armée ladoumègue de céline
aujourd'hui plus personne
plus personne ne nie que les soldats ce
parce qu'ils ont été commandés et qui
sont trouvés dans des conditions proches
de celles de leurs aînés ils sont bien
battus
soixante à soixante-dix mille morts en
six semaines c'est pas rien on écarte
aussi les procès en trahison qui pouvait
être fait à l'extrême droite comme l
extrême gauche contre le patronat qui
aurait saboté la la la mobilisation
industriel ça ne tient pas debout
évidemment il n'y a pas l'ombre du début
d'une preuve on a écarté également les
fautes de la troisième république dans
la mesure où daladier rénaux sont ce
qu'ils sont mais enfin ils ont pris la
décision de faire la guerre et ils la
font et il ya déjà longtemps que le
travail de robert frank avait écarté la
responsabilité supposée du front
populaire
montrant que c'était bien lui qui avait
lancé les forts d'armement français donc
la la la responsabilité de notre
effondrement de mai 40 est due
essentiellement à des fautes commises
par le haut commandement clair qu est-ce
que c'est un est ce que c'est le moment
où il clair aurait pu gagner la guerre
ou et où le corps n'aurait pu la perdre
non si vous voulez là le ce miracle de
dunkerque c'est une expression d'origine
britannique
les britanniques ont effectivement très
honnêtement les britanniques
les documents font foi ne pensez pas
récupérer leurs corps expéditionnaire
jusqu'au 27 mai alors que déjà on
embarque depuis 24 heures
sur ce il pense qu'il faut faire une
croix dessus ça n'entame en rien sa
détermination à continuer la guerre donc
au niveau politique même si la british
expérience force avait été capturé dans
son intégralité
ça ne changeait rien du tout ça ne
changeait même pas dans l'immédiat le
destin de la guerre en afrique et
notamment la la terrible défaite que
vous suiviez les italiens en novembre
1940 hitler a quand même commis une
erreur
c'est incontestable il aurait mieux valu
que les deux cent mille soldats
britanniques soit derrière les barbelés
en allemagne que sur l'île ou après sur
les différents champs de bataille mais
comprend globalement ça ne change pas le
destin de la seconde guerre mondiale et
en aucun cas on ne peut dire que si la
british explique force avec des
prisonnières il terreur gagner la guerre
ça n'a pas de sens
à partir de ce moment là la grande
bretagne se retrouve seul face à
l'allemagne nazie qui va occuper peu à
peu presque toute l'europe
avant de s'attaquer à l'urss en juin 41
c'est quand même assez étonnant parce
qu'il claire rêvait d'une alliance avec
la grande bretagne contre l'urss et il
se retrouve contre la grande bretagne
avec lui à rodez oui effectivement enfin
ce n'est au niveau stratégique il a
tellement commis d'erreur il sait à peu
près toujours trompés c'est à un autre
niveau qu'il est bon mais pas au niveau
stratégique
les britanniques les britanniques sont
pas si seul que ça tout de même en juin
c'est la france qui est bien seul les
britanniques sont
d'abord on leur empire ça n'est pas rien
c'est le quart des terres émergées du
globe et ils peuvent déjà s'appuyer sur
l'industrie américaine
alors certes roosevelt n'a pas encore
réussi à faire basculer l'opinion
américaine dans le camp de ceux qui sont
favorables à une intervention dans une
guerre en europe
enfin tout de même l'appareil de
production américains commencent déjà
travaillé à travailler largement pour la
pour la grande bretagne
churchill a donc deux quand même des
raisons beaucoup de raisons de s'en
faire mais déjà ses yeux sont tournés
plus de washington qui vers moscou
contrairement à ce que pense hitler ça
aussi c'est une erreur d'hitler hitler
pense que si la barre l'union soviétique
churchill n'en a plus d'autre n'aura
plus d'autre raison de ne pas rendre les
armes
c'est à dire il est persuadé que la
dernière épais qui reste à l' empire
britannique
c'est l'épée soviétique ils se trompent
là aussi si on analyse de près dé
l'occurrence on se rend compte que ce
qui importe avant tout à churchill
c'est pas le destin de l'armée rouge
c'est ce que va faire roosevelt et la
puissante amérique tout l'effort de
guerre britannique il est il repose sur
cette idée que il faut que l'amérique
contre en guerre au moment où lula où
l'armée rouge est attaqué le 22 juin
1941 churchill comme les chefs
militaires britanniques comme les chefs
militaires américains est persuadé que
l'armée rouge ne tiendra pas six
semaines donc ça n'est pas un facteur
déterminant pour lui par la résistance
française que c'est sûr on en a parlé
depuis 75 ans alors quel est son bilan
militaire dans les limites de la seconde
guerre mondiale ouvrages dont je parlais
il ya un instant vous avait codirigé
avec olivier wieviorka il ya un chapitre
extrêmement cruelle et pour la
résistance française puisque vous
annoncer des chiffres terribles pendant
toute l'occupation la résistance
française n'a tué que 75 allemand dans
la région parisienne 75 allemands 3
nantes 5 à rouen - 10 à bordeaux
on imagine cette résistance française la
lumière de tous les films qu'on ait pu
voir qui lui sont consacrés faisant de
commettant des attentats
particulièrement meurtriers faisant
exploser des trains remplis de soldats
allemands au souvient du maquis des
glières où souvient du vercors tout ça
au fond c'est hamid
oui c'est un mythe c'est un mythe c'est
à dire si on veut calculer l'apport
militaires de la résistance en termes de
soldats allemands tués ou de matériel
dritte détruits il est dérisoire
bien évidemment ça ne compte pas ça ne
compte pas en revanche il ya un autre
aspect de cette résistance militaire qui
lui n'est pas négligeable
c'est le renseignement c'est là que le
renseignement c'est très important la
résistance française a donné un certain
nombre de tuyaux notamment en prévision
du jour du jour j qui a eu son
importance
les britanniques sont également peuvent
peuvent recouper les informations
qu'elle ordonne le système ultra donc
les fameux décryptage de blush les parts
par les données de la résistance
française qui enregistre par exemple les
départs de sous marins les alliés savent
exactement quand parquet sous marins de
la rochelle de lorient etc
il ya toujours des oreilles ou un oeil
de résistants pour courtrai b et est
informé londres
ça c'est quelque chose d'important mais
aussi un aspect un aspect un aspect
moral les filières de récupération et
d'évasion des pilotes alliés c'est très
important pour les pilotes alliés ils
ont une chance une fois abattu au dessus
de la france de retrouver de retrouver
les îles britanniques
ça aussi c'est quelque chose qu'ils ne
il ne faut pas qu'il ne faut pas
négliger
enfin au fond le général de gaulle on
s'en souvient elle n'était pas pour
cette stratégie d'attentât contre contre
les forces d'occupation
il trouvait ça un peu immoral et puis en
plus ça causait des dommages terribles à
la population civile ont fusillé testage
il était pour que la résistance face du
renseignement et ensuite pour qu'elle
opère une sorte insurrection au moment
du débarquement ça ce qu'est la
politique de l'eau gaulle la politique d
attentat c'est la politique du parti
communiste des francs tireurs partisans
or vous aperceviez après notre comptage
issus des issues des documents de la
police de l'époque non seulement les
résistants français la plupart du temps
communistes eu très peu d'allemand
beaucoup moins que ce qu'il ce qu'ils
disent ou ce qu'ils croient mais qu'il
tue plus de français et d'allemand oui
ça c'est là la résistance c'est une
bière contre les allemands mais c'est
une guerre entre français c'est déjà la
mort une guerre civile
les bilans les bilans ne peut pas les
discuter les historiens ont travaillé là
dessus on a effectivement les français
ont plus tué 11 français qu'ils ont
finalement mais beaucoup plus et je ne
parle même pas de 2,2 de la deûle après
débarquement un jeu a vraiment pas de
l'épuration
on parle de la période de l'occupation
on a effectivement beaucoup plus
descendu de collabo et que de que de que
le soldat allemand c'est incontestable
de gaulle de gaulle pensait très
important l'aspect politique selon il
avait besoin lui c'est que le peuple
français se reconnaissent dans les
organisations politiques de la
résistance qui dépendait de lui c'est un
combat qui lui semblait absolument
central combat qui est mené entre
parenthèses au parti contre les
communistes même il pensait déjà au
coude après c'est à dire à la libération
mais encore une fois s'il s'agit de
répéter ici que la résistance militaire
française est très très faible
on y incluant les maquis oui aujourd'hui
il faut pas se leurrer c'est c'est le
cas vous savez même dans les pays où
cette résistance militaire a été supposé
être la plus forte
je pense notamment à la pologne à la
yougoslavie et à l'union soviétique
ça reste militairement un facteur
négligeable qu'en est il du sort des
juifs en france par comparer évidemment
à aux pays voisins occupait également
par l'allemagne
c'est la sphère du verre à moitié vide
ou à moitié plein ou plus exactement aux
quarts vides et autres cars pleins de
tous les juifs qui vivent en france dont
majorité mais pas touche - das sont
français de nationalité
les trois quarts vont échapper à la
déportation et à la mort ce qui signifie
pso facto qu'un quart noura dans les
camps nazis ou au cours des transports
ou dans les différentes prisons et camps
d'internement si l'on compare avec les
principaux pays d'europe la france s'en
tire évidemment extrêmement bien on a
souvent mis en avant des facteurs de
type géographique notre pays est très
grand il est il est très grand par
rapport à la quantité d'allemands qui
l'occupent 550 mille kilomètres carrés
c'est pas si simple pour l'occupant
allemande le quadrillé la zone sud n'est
pas occupé jusqu'en novembre 1942 on
sait qu'elle assurera un refuge
provisoire mais refuse tout de même à
des dizaines de milliers de juifs
français
mais ce facteur géographique n'est pas
déterminant ce qui semble déterminant au
vu des derniers travaux des historiens
français notamment de jacques semelin
c'est que dans leurs efforts pour se
sauver les juifs français et les juifs
qui vivaient en france et qui n'étaient
pas français ont rencontré un milieu
favorable à leurs efforts je le répète
ils se sont sauvés eux mêmes mais leurs
efforts ont été vains dans un autre
milieu dans un effort pour coup dans
fruits parce que la société française
dans son immense majorité à partir de
1941 n'est pas du tout favorable à la
politique antisémite du maréchal pétain
absolument pas et même une partie de la
police ce qui fait que les différentes
techniques utilisées par les juifs de
france pour survivre la fabrication de
faux papiers par exemple le fait de se
réfugier dans les zones rurales de se
disperser
largement pour éviter d'être concentrés
dans les mêmes régions a pu porter ses
fruits
un certain nombre de réseaux de
solidarité se sont mis en place aux tons
bénéficier les juifs de france
a contrario je dirais l'exemple
antinomique de l'exemple français
c'est l'exemple néerlandais la
communauté juive d'amsterdam notamment
puisque c'était la plus importante
vive est refermée sur elle-même
il y avait relativement peu de contacts
avec avec la communauté la communauté
hollandaise
ce qui fait que lorsque les allemands
occupent les pays en mai 1940 les juifs
vont être une proie facile
ils vivent dans leur quartier ils sont
très facilement dénombrés et ils ne
pourront pas compter sur la seule ride
la solidarité de leurs concitoyens parce
que les réseaux nécessaires n'ont pas
été mis en place
on ne verra pas comme en france par
exemple les colles les instituteurs les
associations de parents aider les
enfants juifs à s'inscrire dans les
écoles avec les autres où on en est on
ne verra pas non plus des fonctionnaires
de police
prévenir à l'avancé des raf
non tout ça n'existera pas je dirais que
c'est un petit peu la rançon de la
politique communautaire de ce point de
vue là qui s'est imposé dans la hollande
dans les pays baltes de
l'entre-deux-guerres cette espèce de
développement séparé on n'est pas
antisémite mais enfin les juifs vivent
entre eux les néerlandais qu chrétiens
vivent entre eux en france vous le savez
le métro de la république saturé telle
assimilation l'intégration complète
c'est très fort c'est très fort et du
coup ces juifs de france que l'on peut
que l'on peut pas repérer il parle
français parfaitement ils sont là depuis
fort longtemps
leurs enfants vont dans les écoles ils
connaissent les y connaissent leur
quartier qu'à l'est et commerçants ils
connaissent des concierges
ils connaissent tous les relais sociaux
dans leur entourage pour eux ça va être
finalement faisable d'échappée
d'échapper au massacre
c'est moins vrai des juifs étrangers à
cause de quelque chose bassett seulement
parce qu'ils sont arrivés très tard ils
ont gardé un accent très fort et restent
concentrés notamment dans des quartiers
de paris fixé autour de métiers
traditionnels chez eux
et évidemment ils ont ils ont ils disent
plonge beaucoup moins de cernay
l'intégration dans la population
française et celle figures dont on a
souvent parlé le roi du danemark
arborant l'étoile jaune
le jour où celle ci est imposée aux
juifs danois est ce que c'est vrai alors
ça ça semble un mythe
ça semble un mythe en revanche ce qui
est avéré c'est que la résistance la
résistance danoise a fait passer tous
les juifs de copenhague
de l'autre côté du jaune c'est à dire en
suède car d'une part c'était pas
compliqué parce qu'il doit y avoir 10 km
et d'autre part je crois que la
communauté doit se monter à 200 250
personnes
donc effectivement les exemples
d'allemagne n'a pas bonne a pas beaucoup
de sens quartette de publier
la wehrmacht la fin d'un mythe un livre
illustré chez perrin vous expliquer dans
ce livre qu au fond longtemps célébrer
l'excellence militaire de la wehrmacht
qui n'aurait au fond c'est dès que parce
que l'ennemi était soit beaucoup plus
nombreux sur le front de l'est soit
avait beaucoup plus de matériel sur le
front de l'ouest
en réalité ce serait plus compliqué que
ça oui maintenant alors d'une peur la
wehrmacht dispose quand même d'un d'un
capital d'expérience colossal avec un
cas ça fait quand même 150 ans que cette
armée cette armée s'est bâti une solide
réputation
elle a un corps d'officiers dans
l'aviation et dans l'armée terre
absolument remarquable ça c'est
incontestable la la la direction des
opérations notamment en matière
terrestres et aériennes reste un de
leurs points forts il est incontestable
qu'ils vont faire souffrir tout de même
une vaste coalition journois jusqu'au
début de 1943 en remportant souvent en
infériorité numérique
un ads des succès succès absolument
gigantesque l'union soviétique a été
payé pour le savoir
elle qui a laissé tout de même plus de
20 millions des siens et on a plus de 11
millions de morts militaires
face à cette vers marc donc c'est quand
même un outil absolument redoutable mais
c'est un outil qui possède de graves
lacunes qui le temps passant vont
devenir de plus en plus pesant
ces lacunes c'est d'abord l'étroitesse
de son appareil industriel
c'est incontestable l'allemagne n'a pas
la voiture pour être une puissance
mondiale
il y monde notamment le pétrole mais
surtout la main d'oeuvre pour pouvoir
concurrencer des géants comme les états
unis l'empiré britannique où l'union où
l'union soviétique c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est la
faiblesse de son appareil logistique
rentrer en russie avec avec des unités
qui sont largement hippomobile c'est
peut-être ce n'était pas forcément la
meilleure chose à faire
il ya aussi beau mobiliser les chefs
tractés par des chevaux tractés par des
chevaux donc lens a dit oui
effectivement c'est quand même c'est
quand même un petit peu juste
il y à aussi fondamentalement comment le
fait que la les chefs de l'armée
allemande sont investissent énormément
le côté opérationnel c'est à dire ils
mènent des batailles pour ce que la
guerre ça se gagne mécaniquement en
menant des batailles en accumulant les
victoires mais ça ne dispense pas d'une
bonne stratégie
or la stratégie allemande est en vérité
une véritable catastrophe
et enfin ce qui leur a manqué c'est
aussi le des alliés des alliés fiables
le les alliances de l'allemagne en
dehors du japon mais qui est une
alliance qui nous a porté les fruits que
13 heures directement et de façon très
lointaine les alliés de l'allemagne ne
sont pas faits pour une guerre moderne
ni la hongrie ni la roumanie ni ni
l'italie ne sont des alliés qui font
qu'ils vont tenir le choc long très
longtemps l'italie va même devenir un
véritable fardeau pour la stratégie
allemande dès 1940
même les finlandais dont on a célébré à
l'envi le courage sont en réalité dans
une situation de stand by à partir de la
fin 1941 et n'apporteront pas non plus
aux allemands le soulagement qu'ils
espéraient donc une armée qui reste une
arme est bonne mais qui restent
handicapés quand même par par tout un
tas de tout un tas de retarder de deux
petits qui vont avec le temps lui peser
de plus en plus et faire qu'elle va pas
être plus être à la hauteur
on voit notamment domaine de l'aviation
la première la première des armes
allemandes kif qui s'effondre c'est la
luftwaffe elle irrémédiablement dit
dépassé à partir de là de l'ani 43 les
plus capables de protéger le ciel du
reich et ça évidemment c'est cette c'est
un échec
absolument considérable et des la
bataille d'angleterre on voit bien une
supériorité indéniable
des anglais il ya cette fameuse phrase
qu'on prête au pilote allemand
on leur demandait qu'est ce qu'il vous
faudrait pour battre les anglais il
aurait répandu des spitfire des la
bataille d'angleterre au fond il ya une
infériorité de la part des allemands
dans le domaine de l'aviation
alors c'est une sincérité qui tient pas
au matériel parce que le mes chers
schmitt sang neuf dans les variantes 40
et 40 1941 40 un travail remarquable et
qui tient tout à fait tout à fait le
coup face pour spitfire ce qui explique
la défaite des allemands dans la
bataille d'angleterre c'est le fait qu'
ils perdent leurs pilotes
quant à pilote est abattu au dessus de
l'angleterre c'est un pilote perdu alors
les pilotes britanniques eux récupèrent
tous leurs pilotes puisque leurs pilotes
sont abattues restent chez eux ou au
dessus de la manche et la royal navy va
les chercher
bon ça c'est le facteur c'est le facteur
le pape seulement le le plus important
le deuxième facteur important c'est
évidemment que les anglais ont une
longueur d'avancé en matière de
détection électromagnétique ils voient
venir les allemands et ça les allemands
ont quand même ils voulaient voit venir
une avec une demi-heure de
d'avertissement préalable ce qui suffit
pour faire décoller les chasseurs non là
la luftwaffe va sujet elle va s'user au
cours des aiguilles et parce qu'elle
intervient partout elles se dispersent
qu'elles fait de mauvais choix
techniques qu'elle opérationnellement
aller de plus en plus soumise à la
demande de l'armée de terre elles
n'arrivent plus à développer une
politique autonome
par exemple ils s'enjaillent la
luftwaffe n'a jamais été capable de
développer de développer un bombardier
stratégique comme les fameuses
forteresses volantes ou les coulées l'an
question où les lancaster et wellington
britannique
ça n'a jamais su le faire et puis le
temps passant tous toutes les
difficultés vont s'abattre sur cette
luftwaffe et notamment de plus en plus
le manque de carburant et le manque de
temps pour entraîner les pilotes
il démarre la guerre en 39-40 avec la
même la même capacité à entraîner leurs
pilotes que les britanniques le même
nombre d'heures
deux ans plus tard ça n'est plus que la
moitié du même nombre d'heures et une
année encore plus tard en 1944
les allemands passent quatre fois moins
de temps à former leurs pilotes que les
britanniques ou les américains je crois
que toute la différence est là
resto sur la wehrmacht un instant on la
trouve formidablement bien équipé en en
melges 20 40 au moment de la bataille de
france on en vit l'équipement des
soldats allemands
quand on voit celui des soldats français
alors d'abord est ce que c'était
vraiment le cas est ce que c'est encore
le cas à la fin de la guerre notamment
quand ils se battent contre les russes
l'armée à l'armée allemande de 1940
finalement les français la connaissent
surtout pour les actualités qu'ils
verront après les fameux deutsche borse
chao qui sont diffusées obligatoirement
dans toutes les salles de cinéma avant
la projection du grand film
ces actualités pour l'allemagne
évidemment ces actualités montre ce que
veut bien montrer goebbels c'est à dire
la partie la plus moderne de l'armée
allemande qui repose c'est à dire une
dizaine de division panzer et quelques
divisions mais motorisés peut-être 10%
mais la réalité c'est que cette armée
allemande de 40 elle ressemble beaucoup
à l'armée française
les divisions d'infanterie marche à pied
les canon de 76 mm sont tractés par des
chevaux comme notre infanterie si vous
mettez côte à côte les division
motorisée pleinement motorisée de
l'armée française
vous trouvez à peu près le même nombre
que celles qui sont motorisées du côté
de l'armée allemande
ça n'est pas véritablement la différence
en termes de quantité et de qualité de
matériel qui a qui a un qui a précipité
la chute de la france en 1940 ça aussi
c'est une idée qu'il faut revenir
même s'il est certain que la france
avait un certain nombre de 2 2 points
faibles notamment dans l'aviation
un mot sur l'italie il clair at il
surestimé la puissance militaire
italienne
oui c'est une de ces grandes erreurs il
va s'en rendre compte que petit à petit
ces mêmes trompés sur le statut de
mussolini
il a vu dans mussolini son alter ego il
pensait que c'était le führer des
italiens en réalité ce n'était que le
premier ministre du roi victor-emmanuel
iii et quand il a à rome en 1938 il est
stupéfait de voir que même du point de
vue de l'éthique est
mussolini ne vient pas au premier rang
ça déjà c'est un c'est un choc pour lui
là
la deuxième chose qu'il a abusé c'est
l'activisme militaire de mussolini
muselier a l'impression qu'il est
partout en 1935 il attaque l'abyssinie
donc les l'ethiopie en 1936 il envoie un
corps à corps expéditionnaire très
puissant et d aider les franquistes
en 1939 il attaque l'albanie et c'est en
1940 que les auditeurs vont souffrir
quand il attaque la france dans les
alpes
quand mussolini attaque la france le 10
juin et qu ils ne parvinrent à rien et
quelques mois plus tard en grèce et
simultanément en afrique
mais ce livre a essuyé alors l'a22
défaite incontestable qui vont permettre
définitivement éclair de comprendre que
décidément c'est pas un cadeau qu'il a
c'est pas un cadeau qui s'est fait à
lui-même qu'en choisissant en
choisissant cette cette alliance
italienne et d'autre part laissé tous
ses services de renseignements il faut
remonter que ni la guerre ni l'alliance
avec l'allemagne nazie ne sont
populaires en italie
au fond cette alliance elle repose
essentiellement sur les rapports
personnels entre le führer et le doute
eu ça ne suffit pas pour faire une bonne
alliance ont fait une pause de quelques
instants jean l'ogc nice on se retrouve
juste après
[Musique]
nous continuons notre émission sur la
seconde guerre mondiale sur le front de
l'ouest pour l'instant avec l'historien
jean lopez de directeur de la rédaction
de du magazine guéret l'histoire jean
lopez est ce que l'allemagne il japon
d'ailleurs avec une chance de gagner là
la seconde guerre mondiale on peut en
douter
soixante quinze ans après oui c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire très honnêtement
je pense que ça n'était pas possible de
quelques façons comprennent le problème
jeu n'ont pas n'ont pas la surface
nécessaire n'ont pas n'ont pas le
potentiel nécessaire le temps que leurs
preuves le temps que l'allemagne
mobilisent à fond son potentiel
militaire ce qui va lui demander juste
d'attendre jusqu'en 1943 il est trop
tard parce que pendant ce temps là
ses adversaires eux ont appris à faire
la guerre en gros si vous voulez de 1939
à 1942
on a une situation qui voit l'allemagne
se battre avec un potentiel industriel
relativement limitées mais elle elle
sait faire la guerre elle a compris ce
que c'est que ce qu'une guerre de
mouvement moderne
elle a donc un avantage opérationnel
incontestable
de leur côté ses adversaires commencent
à faire leur gigantesque potentiel
industriel et humain et ils apprennent
ils apprennent de leurs erreurs
l'armée anglaise de 1942 chelda
l'allemagne elle est bien meilleure que
celle de 1940 l'armée soviétique de
staline gran est évidemment pas l'armée
soviétique de juin 1941
c'est aussi vrai des américains ces
mêmes vrai des forces françaises qui
continuent la lutte sous le drapeau du
général de gaulle
elle se bat mieux que les généraux de 40
donc là ça n'est ça n'était pas de
quelques façons comprennent le problème
je ne vois pas comment à moins de
pousser les uchronies met alors à sont
là avec les avec les ici on fait dire
tout ce qu'on veut à l'histoire et on
n'est plus dans le domaine de l'histoire
mais je ne vois vraiment pas comment
c'était possible pour eux ça se ça se
reflète dans les décisions stratégiques
dit
claire ils trieront n'arrête pas de se
tromper de ce point de vue là en 39 il
pense qu'une fois la pologne écarté il
va peut-être pouvoir se rabibocher avec
les occidentaux
après il est certain que une fois que la
france sera à terre les anglais vont
demander la paix ça il en est sûr il n'a
pas arrêté de le répéter à ses généraux
rien du tout churchill continuer le
combat
après il pense que si si il écrase
l'armée rouge s'il va jusqu'à moscou
seniors se mettaient qui va s'effondrer
non là non plus ça n'a pas marché ces
plans stratégiques parce qu'ils sont
fondés sur des assertions qui sont
fausses
on s'effondrer les uns après les autres
et c'est encore plus vrai des japonais
pensaient que les japonais attaquent à
pearl harbor le 6 et 7 décembre 1941 et
que le 6 mai 1942
cinq mois plus tard ils ont déjà perdu
l'essentiel de leurs porte avions
pendant la bataille de midway
pour eux le rêve dans la durée que cinq
mois c'était une véritable folie quand
on produit 7 millions de tonnes d'acier
de s'attaquer à un géant comme les
etats-unis qui ont produit 92 millions
de tonnes
c'était pas possible quand on arrive à
fabriquer 100 mille automobiles par an
comme c'est le cas du japon de se
mesurer avec un pays qui est capable
d'en sortir 10 millions là rien de jouer
en leur faveur et dès 1942 et 43 les
allemands comme les japonais vont être
littéralement submergés sous un matériel
de qualité servie par des officiers qui
sont deux de meilleur en meilleur avec
le temps qui passe
non je pense que il est absolument vain
de vouloir de vouloir traiter cette
uchronie là est ce que le reich et japon
auraient pu gagner la seconde guerre
mondiale autre aveuglement dites leur
que vous n'avez pas cité c'est qu'il ne
j'ai l'impression ne comprend rien aux
etats unis ils les sous-estiment
totalement sur le plan militaire il leur
déclara la guerre
après pearl harbour parce qu'il est
allié avec les japonais il se pense pas
qu'ils aient conscience au mans il
déclare la guerre
déclare la guerre à un géant est alors
qu'il est déjà en guerre contre un autre
géant à ce moment là qui est l'union
soviétique
ce problème et discuter même par les
historiens allemands parce qu'on va
trouver dans les propos d'hitler
c'est les propos litière varric sans
arrêt d'un jour à l'autre en fonction de
son interlocuteur
on va trouver des affirmations de des
affirmations mépris face aux soldats
américains sera pas capable de mourir
à la différence des soldats allemands et
en même temps une certaine déférence
vis-à-vis du potentiel industriel
américain
il ya dans son entourage un certain
nombre d'hommes je pense notamment à
vars limon qui est un des hauts
responsables opérationnels de l'eau
cabellou commandement de la wehrmacht
il a des hommes qui connaissent bien les
états unis et son appareil industriel
donc il ad'autres son cloche ci déclare
la guerre aux états unis le 11 décembre
1941 c'est parce qu'ils cherchent une
stratégie de rechange après son échec
devant moscou et il pense que la
meilleure façon d'obtenir en de tenir en
lisière
les etats unis c'est de le remettre le
japon dans les pattes
donc quand le japon attaque les états
unis il ils pensent dissuader le japon
de rechercher toute forme de compromis
avec les états unis
en épousant sa cause leur déclarant la
guerre aux états unis il brûle ses ponts
dans ces vaisseaux d'aller à lui en
quelque sorte
mais effectivement il s'est trompé il
s'est trompé sur notamment la capacité
mais tout le monde s'est trompé même
chercher dans partie sur la capacité des
états unis a mené deux guerres en même
temps c'était pas évident de pouvoir
battre à la fois le japon et l'allemagne
en même temps c'est à dire en faisant
porter à la fois son effort dans
l'atlantique et dans le pacifique à la
fois son effort au service de la machine
de guerre américaine
mais en même temps inondé de matériel de
guerre la grande bretagne la france
libre la chine de tchang kaï-chek et
lino soviétique de staline
tout sépare et multiples les américains
les ont tenues de façon extraordinaire
honnêtement je ne connais personne qui
ait projeté une situation pareille dans
toutes les prévisions des années 30
je crois que ça reste une des grandes
surprises de la seconde guerre mondiale
qu'on a pas assez souligné
vous avez dit que hitler c'est
pratiquement toujours trompés sur le
plan stratégique ou et il bosse en
revanche sur le plan de la tactique
militaire par exemple alors tactiquement
il n'y a pas eu la formation à ce camp
avec un caporal de la première guerre
mondiale
mais il a il a un sens assez sûr au
niveau opérationnel
je pense que c'est dicté par un certain
nombre d'impératifs politique chez lui
vous savez en 1939 quand la france et
l'angleterre déclarent la guerre à
l'allemagne
les généraux allemands sont terrorisés
sont pas sûrs du tout qu'ils vont
pouvoir ceux qui vont pouvoir battre
l'armée française d'autant plus qu'il
rentre dans la guerre avec le vieux plan
schlieffen de 1914
j'exagère à peine mais le plan originel
il est de d'envahir la part la belgique
passé par la belgique est ensuite foncé
sur paris par le nord
c'est le plan qu'avait utilisé ce qu'il
fait en 1914 ce plan ne plaît pas à
hitler
pourquoi il ne plaît pas hitler pour
quad et enquête et recherche d'autres
choses parce que c'est un plan il en est
certains qu'ils amènent dans une guerre
longue
une guerre d'attrition hitler c'est
l'homme qui est capable de prendre tous
les risques
parce qu'il veut toujours aller vite il
veut battre l'adversaire le plus vite et
au moindre coût
c'est la raison pour laquelle lorsque ce
général von manstein qui commande un
simple qui qui n'est pas du tout dans
les premiers rangs de l'armée allemande
à cette époque là il est même en en semi
disgrâce depuis la fin 38 quand ce
général von manstein lui amène ce fameux
plan jona qui consiste à prendre une
option incroyable passer par les
ardennes faire passer par les ardennes
100000 véhicules
cette division panzer le meilleur de
l'armée allemande pour crever le front
français là où personne ne l'attend et
filé directement vers la vers la manche
hitler voit le voit le bon dieu venir à
lui c'est exactement ce qu'ils cherchent
ça répond à ces à ses attentes
politiques et j'ajoute
même qu'aujourd'hui on sait on à
plusieurs déclarations que cette idée au
départ c'est aussi ça le d'hitler avant
même qu'elle laisse chez bernstein
iter là il a alors il la développe pas
sur un sur une carte mais il aimait
cette hypothèse d'avancée généraux vous
êtes sûr que c'est pas que c'est pas
plutôt par les ardennes il faudrait
passer
donc il a un il a un sens opérationnel
ah oui c'est incontestable il a sa
principale qualité c'est de devoir les
défauts de ses adversaires de savoir où
il faut les frapper
c'est également usage de la surprise de
la vitesse ça c'est quelque chose qui
l'a accompagné dans sa carrière
politique et qui va continuer à
l'accompagner par la suite il n'empêche
que si globalement sur une feuille de
papier et vous mettez dans la colonne
vous faites une colonne des plus et une
colonne des moins il est certain que
globalement hitler n'a pas rendu que des
services à l'armée allemande
il s'en faut de beaucoup quartier
roosevelt est ce qu'il est ce que la
place un corps des n'ont pas la même
vision de la guerre parce qu'ils n'ont
pas les mêmes intérêts fondamentalement
la grande bretagne ancienne puissance
impériale elle veut garder son empire
c'est la mission que se donne churchill
en mai en 1940 il a donc plutôt tendance
à faire valoir
les outils de la puissance britannique
sa flotte ses positions au moyen-orient
et en méditerranée
la domination du canal de suez bref une
stratégie périphériques qui consisterait
à d'abord affaiblir le point faible dit
l'air las son ami italien en frappant en
méditerranée toute la stratégie de
churchill c'est le ventre mou de lax
c'est persuader les américains qu'il
faut concentrer les moyens sur la
méditerranée la deuxième arbre de
churchill
ce sont les fameux bombardier cradi
moteur là aussi d'y croire il faut mener
une guerre d'attrition contre
l'allemagne
les bombardements de terreurs nocturnes
commence en 1940 et surtout commencent à
s'intensifier à partir de du 31 même du
30 mai 1942 lorsque commence le premier
raid de
le bombardier contre cologne ça c'est sa
deuxième arme les américains voient pas
du tout une stratégie indirecte
il veut au contraire une stratégie
direct du fort au fort quel est le
poumon économique de l'allemagne pour
eux c'est la ruhr
comment est ce qu'on arrive le plus vite
à la ruhr saint débarquant dans le nord
de la france ya 300 km qu'est-ce qu'on
va les faire en italie néanmoins
néanmoins les positions acquises soit
des britanniques
la lenteur de la montée en puissance de
l'armée américaine amène roosevelt a
accepté cette stratégie indirecte
méditerranéenne jusqu'en 1943 et c'est
seulement devant staline
la scène a dû est cocasse
lors de la conférence de téhéran à la
fin novembre début décembre 1943 que
alors que churchill retente le coup de
la stratégie méditerranéenne que la
roosevelt le fêter en l'élisant non au
printemps prochain
on débarque en france d'installer d'un
staline est venu pour chercher cette
promesse et il repart ça va d'ailleurs
changer la stratégie soviétique et il
repart de téhéran avec enfin cette
victoire de de la stratégie
rooseveltienne sur celle sur celle de de
churchill et si on réfléchit quand même
on comprend aussi que c'était l'intérêt
de staline parce que une stratégie
méditerranéenne ça veut dire
éventuellement un débarquement dans les
balkans un débarquement britannique et
américain dans les balkans
or dans dans les objectifs de guerre de
staline ya quand même il ya quand même
le retour le retour d'une d'une zone de
domination soviétique sur les balkans il
préfère voir les américains débarqué en
normandie il a pas de revendications sur
la normandie ça ne l'intéresse pas
plutôt que de les voir s'amuser à
accourir laventure dans les balkans donc
ça l'arrangé ça correspond en même temps
à la vision de la guerre des rose elle
finalement le grand perdant c'est
churchill qui à partir de ce moment là
va vraiment avoir l'impression que face
aux deux grands il est assis sur un
petit strapontin
on reviendra sur un staline dans la
proche
l'émission consacrée au front de l'est
revenons un instant sur de gaulle on a
l'impression que le général de gaulle et
du nez j'allais dire d'une extra
lucidité extraordinaire en juin 40 il
comprend que rien n'est joué que la la
la la battait la guerre n'a été qu'une
bataille en france que tout est encore à
faire
on voit très bien aussi qui comprend que
l'union soviétique à un moment se
retrouvera face à l'allemagne que
l'amérique rentrera dans le jeu on a
l'impression qu'il comprend tout à ce
moment là bien avant la plupart de nos
compatriotes époque il suffit de relire
c'est vrai que c'est assez
extraordinaire et vous avez raison ce
n'est pas assez souvent soulevée suffit
de relire les différents appels lancés
de londres au mois de juin pas seulement
celui du 18 et on est stupéfait de la
qualité de sa vision stratégique quand
ils disent cette cette guerre est une
guerre mondiale la france n'a perdu
qu'une bataille n'a pas perdu la guerre
cette guerre est une guerre mondiale il
existe de par le vaste man 2 des forces
immenses qui n'ont pas encore donné et
il pense évidemment à celle de
l'amérique mais il sait aussi qu'un jour
le torchon déroulera entre hitler et
staline donc bien entendu il a une
vision stratégique
assez assez extraordinaire ce qui est
terrible c'est que cette vision
stratégique eux
elle était aussi chez paul reynaud mais
il ya manqué le caractère à reno il a
vanté le caractère et il était pris par
ces vilaines habitudes politicienne et
le 16 juin 1940 il aurait pu là je veux
faire du ha du et si il aurait pu
peut-être faire valoir cette vision
stratégique parce que lui aussi était
persuadé que la france avait les atouts
de puissance mondiale sa flotte
son empire son or rien n'était joué avec
la bataille de france
sauf qu'ils la jouent lui il a voulu
philo dès avec pétain c'est lui qui
s'est fait avoir
tout ça pour vous dire que de gaulle
n'était pas le seul mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que ça plus sa visite sa
vista stratégique est proprement
extraordinaire faut rappeler que paul
raynaud était le dernier président du
conseil
avant avant un petit pépin avant
maréchal pétain
la française qu'elle joue un rôle dans
la victoire finale ce serait faire
insulte aux deux cent mille soldats
français qui sont morts de prétendre le
contraire
ce qu'on fait leclerc et de lattre de
tassigny en 44-45 mérite le respect
c'est incontestable mais combien de
divisions
bien sûr que nous avons fait tout ce que
nous avons pu pour soutenir l'effort de
guerre alliés jusqu'à la fin pour que
comme disait de gaulle la france figure
au rang des vainqueurs
c'est incontestable mais bien entendu
nous le faisons bien loin bien loin
derrière les soviétiques
d'ailleurs les américains et même
derrière les britanniques même derrière
les chinois en termes de potentiel
investi bien entendu la défaite de 40
est toujours là de gaulle n'a pas grand
chose
ce que nous avons comme matériel c'est
ce que les américains nous octroie et
les stocks qui avaient été cachés par
l'armée de vichy et qu'on va récupérer
vaille que vaille à l'automne et à
l'hiver 44 45
mais si vous voulez me faire dire ce que
je n'ai pas envie de dire je vais quand
même le dire les alliés auraient tout ça
sont du même résultat sans la france
alors comment expliquez vous que nous
nous retrouvons tout de même à la fin
assis avec les vainqueurs nous ne sommes
pas à yalta où on croit en tout cas le
général de gaulle va nous faire croire
construire et partager le monde
nous ne sommes pas à téhéran dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure nous ne sommes
invités nulle part nous avons été
vaincus d'une manière terriblement
humiliante en 1940
nous n'avons joué qu'un rôle symbolique
qu'on va dire dans cette seconde guerre
mondiale à partir de là et pourtant nous
avons non seulement une zone
d'occupation à berlin mais nous siégeons
au conseil de sécurité de l'onu nous
faisons partie des quatre vainqueurs de
la seconde guerre mondiale il y aura des
juges français au tribunal de nuremberg
comment pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que
staline roosevelt
nous on fait ce cadeau alors bien
entendu on n'écartera pas le miracle du
général de gaulle c'est à dire sa
capacité à en tout lieu et à tout moment
à faire entendre la voix de la france ça
c'est incontestable mais on doit une
fière chandelle à churchill en réalité
parce que churchill à partir de 1944 se
projette dans cette europe d'après
guerre et il s'est bien sûr silicone sc
américain on y connaît bien sa mère
étaient américaines cherchent ils
dissèquent les américains vont pas
rester en europe
d'abord parce qu'on pense que la guerre
au japon va durer plus longtemps et on
n'a jamais vu une armée américaine
s'installer longtemps d'occupation le
précédent 1918-19 est dans tous les
esprits
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça veut
dire que l'anglo terme se retrouver seul
face à une puissance qui va 2000 à la
moitié du continent
nyon soviétique l'angleterre c'est
qu'elle n'est pas de taille donc
churchill va tout faire pour jouer la
carte française face à deux hommes qui
lui étaient hostiles un staline comme
nous elles n'étaient pas les amis de
gaulle mais c'est c'est quand même
churchill et sa de gaulle lui rendra
hommage aussi c'est churchill qui
pensent que la france a de beaux restes
quelle est encore une puissance
respectable qu'elle va se reprendre
qu'elle possède toujours son empire
qu'elle a quand même ses 40 millions
d'habitants sa position stratégique en
europe occidentale avec ce pays qui
figure au rang des vainqueurs
on va pouvoir peut-être peut-être
reconstruire une europe de l'ouest
capable de tenir tête à ce que capables
de relever ce que cherchent ils pressent
depuis longtemps être le grand défi de
l'après guerre c'est à dire une présence
soviétique au coeur de l'europe
j'en appelle donc là on a un grand merci
à dire chercher dans la base ce 64ème
anniversaire
commémore la victoire sur l'allemagne
nazie pas sur le japon puisque le japon
que ce sera plus tard néanmoins je
voudrais qu'on dise de mots sur le japon
qu'est ce qu'il va faire capituler le
japon est ce que c'est la bombe
les deux bombes atomiques que les
américains lancent sur hiroshima d'abord
sur magazine qui ensuite ils l'ont
toujours dit les américains ils ont dit
c'est parce qu'on a lancé ces deux
mondes que japon a capitulé si on ne
l'avait pas fait il aurait fallu
conquérir l'île rue par rue appartement
par appartement quasiment alors qu'en
est il en réalité aujourd'hui 75 ans
après qu'est ce que l'on sait la faire
reste discutée entre historiens il n'y a
toujours pas de consensus
vous avez trois écoles qui s'affrontent
la première bon c'est celle classique
qui reprend les paroles de truman qui
justifient d'un usage de la bombe
atomique
devant in arms absolument stupéfiante
dont ils n'avaient pas idée
ce qui est pas tout à fait vrai
d'ailleurs les japonais n'avaient pas
d'autre choix que de capituler
sinon il aurait vu toutes leurs villes
détruites les unes après les autres
c'est faire bon marché du fait que les
américains n'avaient que deux bombes
il n'aurait pas pu tout de suite en
balance et l'autre et que après la
première le gouvernement japonais ne
bouge pas le gouvernement japonais ne
bouge pas et notamment les militaires
les militaires sont au contraire
renforcé puisque finalement pour eux ce
qui s'est passé à hiroshima
ce n'est pas différent de ce qui s'est
passé en mars 1945 à tokyo lorsque les b
29 ont déversé des millions plaquettes
incendiaires il ya eu autant de morts qu
à hiroshima si ce n'est plus donc pour
ya pas de différence de nature
la deuxième école dit non non c'est pas
la bombe atomique qui a fait capituler
le japon c'est la menace soviétique
je vous rappelle que la veille de la
deuxième bombe atomique de nagasaki le 8
août 1945 sous le commandement du
maréchal va signer ce qui les armées
soviétiques lance une offensive en en
tuerie qui va aller beaucoup plus vite
qu'espéré pour détruire les 700000
soldats japonais de l'arb et du queens
tung et leurs alliés du monde choco qui
tentait de garder choses impossibles et
4000 km de frontière commune à l'issue
d'une campagne éclair comme on l'a peu
vu dans l'histoire
l'armée rouge arrive à franchir désert
chaîne montagneuse et et et marécages
pour se projeter 1500 km vers le sud
après avoir écrasé les japonais et se
trouvait sur la frontière de la corée et
en face littéralement à quelques
encablures du japon plus près donc les
américaines le soin à l'époque plus près
que les américaines sont à l'époque avec
une flotte du pacifique intacte
c'est pas une flotte évidemment qui peut
se mesure à celle des américains mais
tout de même avec une flotte avec une
faute de bombardement qui a été
transféré et avec ces millions d'hommes
qui sont qui est maintenant une
expérience du combat assez
extraordinaire
autrement dit l'invasion de la plus
septentrionale des ide japonaise
hokkaido est tout à fait prévisible pour
l'état-major japonais maintenant ce
n'est plus seulement la puissance
américaine au sud qui va falloir
affronter c'est aussi maintenant la
puissance soviétique au nord autrement
dit et les japonais viennent d'être
payés à deux reprises en 1939 à ratingen
déjà en mandchourie et en 1945 à rabin
et sont payés pour savoir que l'armée
rouge n'est plus matière à plaisanterie
en 1945
donc ça c'est la deuxième thèse c'est ça
qui fait ce qui fait céder les
militaires japonais
moi je suis le tenant de la thèse du bon
sens la troisième qui consiste à lire
les japonais ont pesé le poids
exorbitant de ces deux menaces et ont
finalement accepté ce qui était pour eux
l'inacceptable à savoir se rendre aux
américains ils s'y sont d'autant plus
résolus que il ne pouvait pas se rendre
soviétique car se rendre soviétique
ils le savent c'était en même temps
abdiqué leur système politique c'est à
dire le lan pire un set c'était la fin
du techno c'était la fin
l'empereur du japon alors qu'avec les
américains on savait il savait déjà
qu'il y avait toutes les marges de
négociation qui était possible donc
finalement ils se sont rendus au mieux
disant en quelque sorte de leurs deux
adversaires et je pense quant à moi que
les deux leur faisait également peur
dernière question jean le ps pour cette
première émission consacrée au front de
l'ouest
pourquoi les américains mettent ils si
longtemps pour parvenir à berlin on le
sait il ya une campagne de france il ya
la bataille des ardennes il ya la masion
de l'allemagne on sait qu'ils passent
par l'italie également l'afrique du nord
d'abord l'italie ensuite ça a l'air
d'être très très long la campagne
d'italie
on sait que le général patton un des
plus brillants généraux américains
trépigne d'impatience il va être le
premier tout le temps il veut dépasser
montgomery mais à chaque fois il donne
au joueur lui dit non les accords font
que tu passes après montgomery à un
moment ils font ce qu il veut foncer sur
berlin il est persuadé d'arriver à
berlin avant les russes les américains
sont à 150 kilomètres de berlin quand
les russes entrent dans berlin
il est persuadé d'arriver à banteux on
lui dit non il veut aller à prague
on lui dit non qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement c'était les accords il
fallait que berlin soit primes soient
prises par staline et ce serait pour
cette raison que les américains au fond
ne se sont pas pressés les américains
sont avant tout pragmatique
n'oubliez pas que ils ont sur le dos en
permanence les géants américains sur le
dos en permanence des députations de
congressman ne la chambre des
représentants du sénat qui viennent qui
viennent par exemple demander pourquoi
est ce que dans telle bataille il ya eu
autant de pertes qui viennent vérifier
que les blessés sont bien soignés ils
les ont toujours sur le dow première
contrainte
l'armée américaine est une arme est
étroitement surveillée par ce par son
parent sont par son appareil politique
et elle fait extrêmement attention au
centre ces soldats sont une armée de
soldats citoyens
le deuxième point important donc la
dernière contre tyson hour est le
général marshall ne cesse de lui répéter
c'est que l'on pense que la guerre avec
le japon va encore durer longtemps
cette armée américaine qui est engagée
en europe
il va falloir très vite qu'elle retourne
sur les sur en france pour pouvoir être
rien
marquer est réutilisé au pacifique il
n'est pas question de s'attarder en
europe ça si vous laissez les deux
points qui marque la stratégie de asian
hour le troisième point c'est qu'à yalta
le président des états unis s'est
entendu avec joseph staline pour
partager l'allemagne est partagée berlin
à partir du moment où on sait qu'au bout
du compte le résultat politique est
obtenu pourquoi se lancer dans une
aventure car c'est une aventure que de
vouloir s'emparer de vive force d'une
capitale où il ya 3 millions
il ya trois millions d'habitants berlin
est une ville immense et dont on pense
qu'elle sera défendu par les ss jusqu'au
dernier cent us à le voir a été payé
pour savoir à une échelle infiniment
plus réduite lorsque dans l'hiver 44 45
l'américaine s'est emparé d'aix la
chapelle est une toute petite ville on
s'en mord 8000 blessés presque dix mille
pertes pour une petite ville comme ça
mais combien va coûter berlin et
pourquoi faire puisque de toute façon au
bout du compte staline va rétrocéder en
fonction les accords de yalta
il a donc eu un calcul parfaitement
politique tout ce qui s'est dit après
patton qui voulait d'abord patton n'a
jamais été sur la route de berlin il a
été sur la route du sud
et s'ils étaient sur la route du sud
c'est aussi parce qu'elle a les joueurs
pensaient sincèrement que le dernier le
dernier round menée par les nazis et la
ss se ferait dans les alpes c'est la
alpenfestung c'est cette espèce de tarte
à la crème qui a été inventé par
goebbels pour faire peur aux alliés qui
consistait à dire mais nous le troisième
reich qui va durer encore une éternité
sur la forteresse alpine parce que
personne viendra le chercher là bas
autour de berchtesgaden
on a avec des des terrains d'aviation
terré des usines enterrer plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'hommes des
dépôts demi en fait il y avait rien du
tout mais rowsell télé services
américains y ont cru à ce bobard
c'est la raison pour laquelle des armées
américaines ont tourné vers le sud
berlin
berlin face à ça donc des motifs
politiques la volonté d'épargner le sang
des soldats et ce bobard de la
forteresse des alpes
à mon avis explique suffisamment bien
l'attitude d'eisenhower tout le reste
est spéculation de l'époque de la guerre
froide
merci jean lopez ici se termine cette
première émission consacrée à la seconde
guerre mondiale le front d'ouest on se
donne rendez vous pour la prochaine
consacré au front de l'est toujours avec
jean lopez
merci de nous avoir suivis
[Musique]